you
the order was originally formed as a
means to go hand in hand and fight
against a freeze humanity was at the
time at war with the half-breeds and
they had a hard time surviving the
half-breeds were fewer but they were
definitely more powerful this point in
the story the order has realized that in
order for them to finally win the battle
over the half grades they have to
Commission the best weapon makers are in
the world to make the things that they
need to fight whatever was that they
were coming up against and that war that
remains a status quo for the better part
of like you know a thousand years
suddenly changes with the Industrial
Revolution because now that equilibrium
is changed by machinery and inventions
we started looking at what are the
things that we think are interesting to
propel something to weaponize something
it took a lot of iteration to get
something that looked at the
craftsmanship of the period but also you
had this alternate technology that you
had to integrate into just the basic
assault rifle there's definitely
prototype weaponry at that time where
some of the guns makers were developing
automatic weapons out of their
semi-automatic weapons so we thought a
rifle that was fully automatic with
something that they would have figured
out designing you know the Knights kind
of bread and butter which is the combo
rifle that was kind of the challenge of
you know just looking at all the issued
rifles through all the ages and
industrial evolution up to World War two
and trying to pick the tone of what we
wanted to hit so we attempted to make a
Victorian version of the ak-47 plus this
kind of alternate fire at the time they
had originally called it there was
something called a combo gun but it was
a rifle shotgun set up so we kind of
took the name leaving the form factor of
the kind of master key set I've been
changing the shotgun up or something
that delivered kind of like a concussive
blast
there's plenty of conventional weaponry
that feels like it fits in in that era
but then there's a little more kind of
prototype weapons that are definitely
kind of pushed in terms of what was
available in the time for years and I've
been watching videos like online of you
know thermite's this cool thing you know
people don't really know much about it
but you ignite this aluminum oxide
powder and it turns into this big like
sparking you a thing that can weld it
can cut that's exciting let's figure out
how to make that it kind of spits out
projectile thermite pellets that you can
spray anyway and then you take a
high-temperature flare throw it into
that cloud and then it ignites
everything you could do in that order
but what if you were to actually fire
the flare first set that up and then
spray the thermite and after it's got
multiple different ways you can play it
that's interesting so he's kind of kept
them going down that path of figuring
out what things that maybe you know
don't get a lot of exploration in other
games for weapon ideas we wanted to make
sure nothing felt too contrived so we
went to a meticulous level of research
and in trying to find as we're putting
together these slightly fantastical
devices how we can make them feel
grounded in the technology of the era
we're looking at Edison and Tesla and so
we said okay electricity has got to be
something that we play with everything's
being electrified at the time period so
let's put that in one camp we've
actually used Tesla's one of our main
points of contacting again he provides
weaponry he provides devices that he
invents and sometimes based on actual
real things that he's done because he's
kind of like in our game a little bit of
a makeshift kind of MacGyver you know
he's crafty he doesn't necessarily put
things together in the most beautiful
way but for him it makes sense you never
cease to amaze Nikola so we said okay
maybe he took these leftover parts of a
rifle the for stock and he just started
whittling and cutting it down adding
some other pieces to it even though
they're their gadgets of weapons that
didn't exist in that time period they're
made from components and ideas and
research that were available then
especially the art gun when it kind of
unfurls and it starts charging up and we
thought okay well it's kind of cool if
maybe it spins up generates electricity
and that thing that kind of stores
itself along a Jacob's Ladder like
apparatus that is also the aiming part
of the weapon and then that thing finds
its way kind of arcing towards its
target and what
it's it delivers you know so much energy
that whatever hits pretty much atomizes
and blows it up people are developing
these gadgets that you know a breakneck
pace and not really considering kind of
the safety of the user we wanted to make
make it feel like it's sort of on the
edge of what is safe to wield especially
some of the prototype weapons where part
of the allure of them to us was that
thing looks kind of unstable that looks
just as dangerous to the operator as it
does the two lovers on the receiving end
you know so that's kind of some of the
fun of the weapons while they don't
necessarily look comical we tried to
always make them look like i said you
know realistic and classy that there's
an element of kind of danger in some of
them they actually feel a little bit on
the edge it was a question of
understanding what it was about the
werewolf more that is as intelligent as
you are but he says be still as a walk
those things